TODAY IS DAGEN McDOWELL
MORGAN ORTAGUS AND BRIAN
BRENBERG IT'S GONNA BE SPICY.
YES, PRESIDENT BIDEN DOES HOW
THIS FIRST FACE-TO-FACE MEETING
WITH CHINA'S PRESIDENT SINCE SHE
TOOK OFFICE.
THE TENSION BETWEEN THE TWO
COUNTRIES HERE AT HOME IS PRETTY
TOUGH.
THERE WERE OTHER LEADERS SPOKE
ABOUT TAIWAN, ECONOMIC
COMPETITION, AND INFLATION
ACCORDING TO A READOUT OF THE
THREE HOUR LONG MEETING THE
PRESIDENT DID NOT A JUMPS SET
NOW COMING FROM CHINA.
AND THE LEADERS OF COURSE, AND
THE ORIGINS OF COVID WAS NOT ON
THE LIST.
HE DID USE THEIR SET DOWN TO
RESTART DIALOGUE ON CLIMATE
CHANGE.
AND HE ALSO SAID THAT INSTEAD OF
PUSHING CHINA TO ANNOUNCE
VIOLENCE AND WARFARE, WELL
WATCH...
>> I AM NOT SUGGESTING THAT
THIS IS KUMBAYA, EVERYONE'S
GOING TO GO LAY WITH AGREEMENT
BUT I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS A NEED FOR CONCERN AS ONE OF
YOU RAISE THE RELIGION MY
QUESTION AND COLD WAR.
AND I THINK THAT, I WILL
CONCLUDE BY SAYING IT THIS WAY.
, I WANT TO BE CLEAR AND BE
CLEAR OF ALL THE LEADERS BUT
PARTICULARLY WITH XI JINPING
PRESIDENT OF CHINA.
LET ME WHAT I SAY AND I SAY WHAT
I MEAN.
SO THERE IS NO MISUNDERSTANDING.
>> MORE AGAIN, I WAS SAFE FOR
THE COLUMBIA, CAN BUNNY AT
GEFFEN FOR A MOMENT BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT HE MEANT OR WHAT
HE SAID BUT ANYWAY TAKE IT AWAY.
>> Morgan Ortagus: ELLA SOME
OF THE POSITIVES OF THE
NEGATIVES.
I'VE BEEN A PART OF MEETINGS AND
STUFF LIKE THIS ENTRY AND A HALF
HOURS IS A LONG MEETING SO
THERE'S CLEARLY A LOT THAT THEY
COVERED IN THAT TIME.
WHICH IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IT IS THE FIRST TIME
THERE WERE FACE TO FACE AND EYES
HAVE BEEN SAYING I THOUGHT THAT
THE PRESIDENT WOULD BE SETTING
BITING THE WAY PUT IN DID BEFORE
HE INVADED UKRAINE.
SO THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING OF THE
INFANTS CONCERNED ABOUT.
SO THE LENGTH OF THE MINUTE WAS
GOOD AND I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
GOOD THAT THE CHINESE AND
AMERICANS HAD A JOINT STATEMENT
THAT REITERATED BOTH OF THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE THREAT OR USE
OF THREAT OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN
UKRAINE.
WHY'S THAT IMPORTANT?
BECAUSE POLLUTANT IS NOT
BASICALLY BEHOLDEN TO CHINA, AGG
PINK AND POLLUTANT HAS BEEN
THREATENING CRUDE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS WILL BE BACK FOR THE
PARENT PLANET SO THE FACT THAT
HE CAME OUT AND SAY THAT THOSE
ARE TWO POSITIVE THINGS THAT I
SEE.
BUT THE NEGATIVE COMING OUT OF
IT, AND HE SAID THIS EARLIER
WITH DANA IT'S A HUGE MISTAKE TO
MAKE CHINA, TO MAKE CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT NUMBER ONE PRIORITY
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
THEY'RE BUILDING MORE CLEARANCE
THAN EVER THEY'RE NOT GONNA GET
THEIR WORDS IN THE BEGINNING
WHEN YOU POINTED OUT WHY WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT FAT NOW, THE
CHEMICAL FREIGHT KNOW THAT GO
FROM CHINA TO MEXICO THE NUMBER
ONE KILLER OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHY
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE ORGANS OF
POISON 19?
I WOULD GONNA LET THEM GET AWAY
WITH THAT THEY'VE NEVER HAD AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION.
NEVER ALLOWED INDEPENDENT SITES
TO COME IN, AND TO TELL THE
WORLD TO LET THE TRUE ORIGINS OF
COVID IS.
WE JUST CAN'T LET THEM GET OFF
SCOT-FREE?
>> Harris Faulkner: ON THE
COVID ISSUE I MEAN TYLER
WOULD'VE BEEN PART OF THIS.
THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN OTHER
COUNTRIES WHO WOULD'VE JOINED US
SO WOULD HAVE JUST BEEN NICE.
WE MAY HAVE MISSED THE DATE ON
THAT DULL.
WE DO NOT KNOW BECAUSE
APPARENTLY WE ARE TOO WEAK OR
WHATEVER THE WORD IS TO EVEN ASK
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY AGAIN.
IT IS NEVER TOO LATE TO DO
SOMETHING GREAT, BUT IT MIGHT BE
TO GET THINGS STARTED.
BUT THE WHOLE TIME HE WAS
TALKING, IT WAS THAT WE WERE IN
CHURCH AND YOU WERE NODDING.
SAYING AMEN LIKE THE REVEREND IS
SAYING AMEN.
>> Brian Brenberg: AHMED MAYS
WITH MORE AGAIN, IT'S A GREAT
WAY TO START IT.
AND YOU WERE GOOD WITH THAT.
AND I'M WATCHING THIS THING AND
ALL I SEE IS PRESIDENT G IN FULL
THROTTLE DOMINATION MOTIVE FOR
THE STAGE AND I'M WATCHING OUR
PRESIDENT WASHINGTON THAT.
AND HE IS NOT IN THE POSITION OF
STRENGTH.
AND THEN TO HAVE CLIMATE CHANGE
BE THE HEADLINE ISSUE HERE?
THEIR BUILDING CORP. HATS ALL
OVER THE PLACE.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTING IN
CLIMATE CHANGE OBJECTIVES UNLESS
IT IS TO CONSTRAIN THE U.S.
ECONOMY.
>> SO LET ME FOLLOW UP WITH
THAT, BECAUSE WHEN WE HAVE SEEN
THE PRESIDENT CAPITULATE AND
DIFFERENT ENERGY ISSUES, I GUESS
YOU CAN ASK SANITY MANSION.
BECAUSE HE COULDN'T HAVE SEEN
THE PRESIDENT SAYING WHAT HE DID
IN RECENT DAYS THAT WERE GOING
TO SHUT OUT THE COAL PLANTS.
SO WHAT IS HIS PLAN?
HE'S GONNA MAKE EVERYTHING HERE
NOT SUFFICIENT NEVER TO BE
BUYING COAL FROM CHINA NEXT?
JUST WHAT WERE BUYING OIL?
>> Brian Brenberg: AM ALSO
BUYING BATTERIES FROM CHINA AND
THEY PUT IN A STRONGER POSITION
THAN WE HAVE NOW.
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA MUST LOOK
AT PRESIDENT BIDEN COMING TO
THIS MEETING AND THIS IS
SOMEBODY HE KNOWS HE CAN
OUTMANEUVER IN EVERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF THE DAY.
AND THERE IS NOTHING, THE
POSITIVE POINTS ASIDE, I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
PRESIDENT BIDEN DID ON THAT
STAGE TO CHANGE THE GAME FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
AND THIS IS A GAME WE WILL NOT
WIN OVER THE LONG TERM IF WE
KEEP PLAYING IT.
>> AND THE BODY LANGUAGE IS
VERY TELLING, WHEN THEY CAME
TOGETHER FOR THE PICTURE WHICH
THE STATE OF HEADS ALWAYS DO
THEY TRY TO SMILE BITING DEAD
BUT USING PAGES THAT THEY LOOK
STIFF AS A BOARD.
>> HE'S NOT CONFUSED ABOUT OUR
RELATIONSHIP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT HE KNOWS THAT
THERE'S A COLD WAR.
>> WHEN YOU GO ON A DATE WITH
SOMEBODY AND SOMEBODY LOOKS LIKE
THEY'RE INTO THE MOVIE AND
EVERYONE KEEPS GETTING UP TO GET
POPCORN...
THAT IS BASICALLY IT.
HE KNOWS THAT WE ARE NOT
FRIENDS.
AND HE TREATS US ACCORDINGLY.
>> HE TREATS US AS IF WE ARE
SUCKING UP TO HIM, AND THAT WE
ARE INFERIOR TO CHINA.
CERTAINLY BASED ON JOE BIDEN'S
POLICIES AND HIS LANGUAGE THAT'S
HOW HE BEHAVES.
IT IS NOT SO MUCH THE EYES OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO STAND UP FOR
THE SURVIVING FAMILIES OF THE
MILLION AMERICANS, MORE THAN A
MILLION AMERICANS WHO DIED FROM
COVID-19.
IT IS NOT TOO MUCH FOR HIM TO
SAY THAT CHINA, WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT THE ORIGINS WHETHER IT IS
TO LATER NOW IT IS NEVER TOO
LATE FOR THOSE SURVIVING
FAMILIES TO HEAR THAT FROM THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT IS NOT TOO LATE FOR THE
FAMILIES OF THE TENDONS KNOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DIED FROM
PROFESSIONAL POISONINGS HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
SO BY THEN, CANNOT STAND UP FOR
ALL OF THOSE FAMILIES BUT HE
CAN'T STAND UP IN FRONT OF THE
WORLD AT THE TOP OF THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE AND HUMBLE BRAG ABOUT
THE DEMOCRATIC VICTORY IN THE
WET TIMES.
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT HE DID SO
INSTEAD OF EMPATHY FROM THE SKY,
WE GET ANTIPATHY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AND WHILE MY THING ABOUT ART
RELIANCE ON CHINA, SO CLIMATE
CHANGE IS THE ISSUE BUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AND BIDEN'S PUSH TOWARDS
GREEN ENERGY HAS CONTINUED TO
ENRICH CHINA.
AS MIKE AND SHELLENBERGER HAS
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS REPEATEDLY
SPENDING 300 DOLLARS AND THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT
SUBSIDIZES SOWS OF PANELS AND
WIND TURBINES AND MAKES TERM
CHINA WERE RICHER AND STRONGER
BECAUSE OF IT.
WHEN SOLAR AND BATTERIES REQUIRE
1000% MORE STEEL, CONCRETE GRASS
ALL OF THAT AND CHINA'S MARKET
OF MATERIAL IS ALREADY TWICE OF
OPEC'S SHARE OF OIL.
>> Harris Faulkner: THAT'S
WHAT WERE TALKING ABOUT WITH
THOSE BATTERIES.
I DO WANT TO GET TO THIS AND
THEN EMILY I WILL COME STRAIGHT
TO YOU, AND WE DO NOT MAKE LIGHT
OF THIS IS JUST SORT OF THE
SIGNATURE HERE'S WRITING.
>> I'M HEADING DOWN FIRST OF
ALL, GOING TO CAIRO FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL EFFORTS.
THAT I'M HEADING OVER TO
COLUMBIA AND THEN TO CAMBODIA.
IN THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE.
I WANT TO TELL -- >> AND I
KNELT HARRIS AFTER THAT THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA OF COURSE SAID
IN COMPARISON TO TRUMP THIS WAS
SIMPLY A BUG BITE VERSUS A
MOUNTAIN.
SO MY MATTER WHAT THEY KNOW MANY
OF THE DISRESPECT THAT
ILLUMINATED TOWARDS OUR ALLIES
WERE SIMPLY OVERSHADOWED BY THE
MEDIA'S OBSESSION WITH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT UP
THE BODY LANGUAGE OF BITING AND
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA BECAUSE
YOU GUYS ARE SEEING THE WILDLIFE
VIDEOS OF THE COUGAR STOCKING OR
MAYBE A RABBIT OR HIKER OR
SOMETHING, THAT IS WHAT IT LOOK
LIKE.
THIS BOLD LOVING LABRADOR ONCE
ACROSS THE STAGE OF HIS HEAD OUT
THE WHOLE TIME AND AS A COUGAR
SITTING THERE BECAUSE THIS
SECRETARY POMPEO AS HE
ARTICULATED SO BEAUTIFULLY AND
SO COMMITTED AFTER WE SAW'S
COMMENTS LIVE HE SAID, AND HE
TALKS ABOUT COMPETING WITH THE
CONFRONTATION AND COMPETITION IS
A REALLY UNDERWEIGHT.
THE CCP HAS BEEN INSIDE THE
GATES FOR THE LAST DECADE.
AND THERE ARE CIDER
UNIVERSITIES, OUR RESEARCH
SYSTEMS, MILITARY INSTALLATIONS,
WE NEED TO GO AT IT
DIPLOMATICALLY POLITICALLY
MOMENTARILY MILITARILY,
ECONOMICALLY AND ALL OF THESE
RUINS EACH OF THEM AND TO SEE MY
OPINION THAT FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO SAY ALL -- NO -- WE'VE BEEN
ON THE SAME PAGE ARE ALL ABOUT
CLIMATE, THERE'S NO
CONFRONTATION, JUST SUCH A
DISSERVICE TO THE ORDINARY
AMERICANS THAT IS BY FEELING THE
EFFECTS OF CHINA'S DOMINATION
THAT HAS BEEN BATTLING THE
EFFECTS AND TAXES, AND IN FEES,
AND IN SHODDY PRODUCTS, THE
UNDERLINING OF THEIR AMERICAN
PRIDE, NON-AMERICAN PLACEMENT IN
OUR PRIORITIES.
ALL OF THAT IS BECAUSE OF THE
CCP'S HAVE TAKEN OVER.
THE PRIOR ADMINISTRATION HAD A
GREAT HANDLE AND PRIORITY ON AND
NOW THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES
NOT.
>> Harris Faulkner: LOOK, I
KNOW WE HAVE TO GO HERE AND I
WOULD JUST SAY THIS...
IF YOU CAN'T BE ON THE WORLD
STAGE NOW, AND YOU ARE A HUMBLE
GUY AGAIN ABOUT THE FACT THEY
JUST WON THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS
THAT WERE LOST A FEW RECEIPTS
AND ANY PRESIDENT A FEW YEARS
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
HE SAID PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IF YOU CAN'T TAKE THAT MOMENT,
IF YOU CAN'T GRAB THAT MOMENT TO
HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE ON THINGS
THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA, IF YOU
CAN'T BRING UP THE WEEK IS TO
SAY YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THEM
WOULD YOU EVER DO IT?
IS THE ANSWER NEVER?
OK